you know i made a mistake i saw a man
the other day
and he was in a um in a
he had a hat on right you know he had
that brim
and so i went up and it said mariners
you know and so i said oh you know are
you a big fan you know i said
unfortunately you guys are one of the
only teams never to win the
the pennant you know the championship
the major league championship
and he's just look he said excuse me i
said
you know we're you guys are one of the
you know seattle you guys are one of the
only teams
you know to never win it it's
unfortunate
and he's just you know i said you know i
was a saints fan and they they had
they didn't win it for 30 years and
you know i know your pain a little and i
said you know
and he's just kind of looking at me when
i said you know i love ichiro
and i always have really you know
enjoyed ichiro suzuki if you if you've
seen him or if you haven't
he is a man and i'm not gonna
you know racially profile him but
you know he could be bobby lee's daddy
i'll say that
you know you wouldn't be surprised if
you looked up the sung
sang dynasty and he was in one of the
arts
you know one of the drawings or whatever
but um you know i said i love dichyro
you know tino martinez i'm rattling off
different mariners players
and he's like what are ex what are you
and at this point i can tell he's
getting a little upset and i started to
think something's wrong i started to
feel high honestly
and he's like what in the [ __ ] are you
talking about
i said the mariners and i pointed his
hat and it said
marines on it
and uh
i mean just damn you know just
nothing there's something when you ask a
member of an armed force
you know when you ask a man who is a you
know a warrior
who's traveled to other lands you know
to
you know to fight and you know try and
you know hook up with women on his off
days and
you know or be secretly in love with man
or whatever
you know a military when you ask a man
like that and you just repeatedly kind
of accuse him of being a
seattle mariners fan it's
well it's not something you want to do
good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one ah